you guys feel bad when you hear
situations like this because sometimes I
feel like you deserved it dude you
alienated everyone close to you you
chose career money over well maybe we
don't know that he alienated everyone
closer yes we do we judge it at the
beginning of the video yeah dude we've
already said it sentence three minutes
in don't contradict the guru
[Music]
this is a pretty crazy story that
happened over in uh Malibu this got
uncovered after uh this physician this
doctor guy who was like a big investor
made a lot of money he passed away and I
think his family was looking into what
happened to his finances and they
uncovered this whole crazy scheme
basically
um you have this guy in Malibu he's a
doctor he's also suffering interestingly
enough from mental problems towards like
later in his life
um he ends up having these like fits of
uh hallucinations whoa and uh so he's
unable to work things like that he meets
these two people
um this Fresno hair stylist and then
this other girl who like teaches yoga
it's like this guy and girl they realize
that this dude's kind of going crazy
that he's very rich so then they act
like they become best friends with them
they over the course of a long period of
time they basically become his best
friends slash care givers and then they
get him to sign over power of attorney
so that they can go ahead and get him
the medication he needs that they can uh
get him into the you know the
appointments that he has to have for his
health and all these things this guy
doesn't have family not family that's
close enough to care for him like this
wow and I think like people just assume
like those are his friends yeah and so
what they do is they end up moving into
his mansion with him and uh basically
over time they get him to uh after he
signed over power of attorney they're
able to open up bank accounts in which
they can move money from one account to
the other So eventually they take uh it
says exceeding 20 million oh my God he
doesn't have anybody who likes him I
mean looking out for him
sometimes people are just driven and
lonely you know and the worst part is
this story is not uncommon does he have
a family who like he is strange because
he like [__] dumped his old ass wife
or some young chick I think it's one of
those things where they just assume he's
okay because there's because those two
are doing a really good job of keeping
everything like so they're like oh isn't
that nice
advocate here you said it was over a
long period of time though right yeah so
maybe it was well deserved and earned
true they work for them because he is
taking care of them they are they all
dealt with me he's got nobody else yeah
he needs somebody anyway to get him
whether it be the medication or the care
or whatever hey wolf boys I was thinking
the same thing what kind of the guys he
can't spend that 20 million anyway it's
like five years of this hey dude give
him the money bro what kind of [__]
did they have to deal with yeah with him
yeah they'd uproot their own lives and
move into his poor little Mansion this
poor girl can't teach yoga anymore man
so the party's taking care of this guy
the part that's really [__] up is that
like I don't know oh [__] [__]
damn it dude so uh wolf boys they know
that his mental health is deteriorating
that he's just kind of like going
bonkers so they set up a bunch of like
um cameras in his house and they gave
him a ton of drugs like all Anthony I
can't believe you supported these
[__] people I said the devil
supported him I was only speaking
through him not too long I warned you
about the line with these dancers they
gave him like a bunch of LSD and stuff
to make him like go maximum crazy and
then they left and they just kept him in
a room and watched him on the cameras
and waited for him to die they should
have done that amount of nutrition and
how long did it take for them to die it
doesn't say I think that's some [__]
up [__] just kill him like he just did
so much of it yeah oh you already spent
five years just wait it out yeah and
then all clean I know and how did these
two get caught they got caught when
um they didn't autopsy oh no it just
looked like the guy did that on his own
but then um they got caught eventually
because after he passed and his the
family that he does have that has a
responsibility to like look over
everything that happened started seeing
all these other accounts and all these
things and they were like you didn't why
would you do this all this transactions
why would you make so many accounts and
move so much money and then eventually
like it's moved it's gone the money just
disappears so they're like where's
where's it all going and then they
that's when you needed somebody inside
the family to be like oh well he's
probably just like you know too [__]
up he's moving money around accounts
yeah but what I really what I think
what I think it really is is that
because it says that the FBI and IRS
were investigating it I think they just
messed up on paying the taxes that he
owed when the IRS wants to find where
the money is they will find that and
that's how they uncovered all these like
different branches and then figured out
that they were the two that were doing
so they took 20 million dollars from
those days in excess of it because it
says that they have brought them in
terms of hold Hard Cash 2.7 million in
terms of estate values dude exceeding 20
it says you do 2.7 million cash you get
out dude that's it dude they get greedy
though you get greedy the next part is
the hardest part the laundering is
always the hardest part oh interesting
no you buy a plane right yeah Joe's like
how do you burn the trail like not too
many things what are you talking about
you take [__] to the Pawn Stars
we've gone over this like put it all in
a Cavalry sword yeah and like you spent
nothing on it so when Rick Harrison
tries to lowball you you're like yeah
okay dude I guess I'm getting wrecked on
this deal cool 300 bucks
so are these people caught they're
caught they are facing up to 20 years in
prison for each fraud count and they
caught like the the video footage like
they saved all that that's that's
[__] they at least live large for a
little bit they did they did for the for
the years that they were with them while
they were convincing him that he was
their best friend they were living off
of his money and all the love but why do
they have to kill the dude like me he
must have been really annoying I mean
because like if he was really cool then
it's like well I would just [__] it
we're living good he was such a
dependent I think yeah and they're like
I'm tired as he's like wiping his ass
yeah they basically just got to that
point probably they're like you know
what let's just off them by using
cameras that we played yeah
LSD that we give him you guys feel bad
let's give ourselves evidence nobody
would know you guys feel bad when you
hear situations like this because
sometimes I feel like you deserved it
dude you alienated everyone close to you
you chose career money over well maybe
we don't know that he alienated everyone
close to it did we judge it at the
beginning of the video yeah dude we've
already said it sentence three minutes
in don't contradict the guru it's
definitely sad if he was a good yeah
good things for people and then he just
started to Goku are you on our team Ryan
no sensing something here we're at his
age
he has nobody close enough to 57 yeah he
has nobody close enough to him he's got
the yoga instructor well maybe he
doesn't have anybody close enough to
think like you know when when
you this might have happened in the past
where you have a friend they get some
new friends and then you go oh he's cool
no I just destroy him and make sure his
friends hate him too
do they have sun-kissed hair like I have
picture yes they probably look like a
bunch of surfers yeah yeah let me let me
take some time for this video Malibu
crew huh
I was trying to just guess without
asking [__] Malibu yeah but they're
from Fresno they should look way more
[__] dirtier oh yeah that's right
they're from Fresno they're not from
Malibu but they spent five years in a
Malibu mansion you acclimate quick bro
yeah you're gonna turn into La super
quick try drinking smoothies every
morning from that [__] uh what's
erwan or something
they look like arowan people this is the
two of them dude I [__] Russell Brandon
Gigi Hadid I did so he's the he's the
Fresno hairdresser and she's the yoga
instructor damn dude they look Posh bro
they're very Posh it's funny because
this is gonna make a good movie they're
trash they're not rich they're just con
artists I love painting games I was
thinking the same thing which ones that
was the one with the Rock and Mark
Wahlberg yeah yeah I believe in the
American dream in the land of second
chances they're basically um like Laurel
Canyon grifters
yeah they have that like feel right yeah
yeah yeah they're probably buying stones
and they look like moms they look like
Mamas and Papas do some Aaron Rodgers
[__] yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah were they
a couple or just friends
um it says they were busting it says
they're a couple but I don't know they
could just be friends they could have
been a throuple he's like hey I swing
both ways I'll suck your dick and
[__] eat a [__] yeah you know and
then he's all like do we need that
exactly
your honor it says here you know how
people like us do you guys remember Anna
Nicole Smith and then they're just
they're just like I can't believe this
gold digger and I'm all like yo if you
had a suck 90 year old dick it's like
hey if that's that's hard work too she
was [__] a Crypt Keeper dude suck a
dick her whole life like you think it's
like a 90 year old dick sucks it
probably comes like within 12 seconds
wow she's like this is the dream yeah I
just remember thinking if that's the way
that guy wants to go out who are we to
judge yeah exactly it's a Texas oil been
in there and he's like God damn it this
27 70 year old woman [__] loves me
and that's America that's what America's
about yeah Freedom baby land opportunity
Second Chances that's what America's
about yeah I'm telling him but yeah they
um they were not successful in their big
scheme
it's just said that they didn't have to
kill the guy yeah they always do you
just take a little bit and leave 2.7 mil
cash how did how do you spend 20 mil
dude it's like hey how many how many um
what's that movie with George Clooney
where he's stealing [__] oh she's 11.
how many [__]
gonna look yeah you know what I mean
three yeah they couldn't they wouldn't
happy stealing one yeah that's the guy
that does your media barbell right but
it wasn't about the money Steve what
about the money but the Revenge it's the
rush yeah that's true that's true and
all three of them were not bad why'd
they have to make Oceans Eight okay you
know why because girl power bro girls
get steal too I like having a noodle arm
and like did women support oceans 8
most girls I know I never watched that
one honestly most girls don't watch
movies bro
when I when I'm trying to get my girl to
watch the movie with me she's just on
her phone and that's so you know what
out of 10 before right now yeah
it's a [__] four negative three I'll
meet you there too I'll deduct as well
because I have the same movie panes as
well yeah right where you see in the
corner tonight that they're just
yeah and did you mind like this is the
best part this is the best part and
comments don't ask me if it's a movie
that she wants to see it's never a movie
she want to see it's a movie I want to
[__] see
what is the movie no Marie Antoinette
love me and watch it with me what is the
movie she would want to say Downtown
Abbey uh downtown hobby [__] King speech
nah she would never watch that I
remember a movie I remember we tried
watching uh everybody everybody was
talking about La La Land Steel Magnolia
and we and we should we turn it on [__]
it let's watch it that's a good movie
though three minutes in Tiff was like
turn this [__] off
I like the first half she's like the
credits are offensive I like the first
half you didn't like the whole thing
yeah we couldn't get into it I couldn't
get into it you guys have terrible taste
but that's what I was like Matrix
Revolutions put it on
yo have you seen the latest hey cut to
the Zion seeds I'm sick of this major
[__] cut the Zion scene Loki though
I'm terrible tape
that's the best Matrix basic revolutions
have you seen number four which one was
that one oh my God that one that was the
best one the best one they ever made
shut up it doesn't exist shout out to
the hotel before it's really just number
one today number four never happened
dude number four is the best